Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking you today.
Hey,
what's going on?
How are you?
It's a really Thursday afternoon.
Um,
I forgot it was Thursday.
Had been so fucking busy doing something that I'm not allowed to announce yet.
And Wink,
wink,
wake,
wink.
Um,
for whatever can reason.
And uh,
my phone shit,
the bed,
my phone,
shit,
the bed,
my fucking bread.
Um,
a phone,
shit,
the bed.
And uh,
so I had to go over to Verizon
and uh,
see what the fuck was wrong with.
It turns out when I went to old Canada,
none of our teams are in the playoffs,
but we still have syrup.
Let's all start a fucking riot.
When I went up there,
I didn't have a cell phone plan,
so Verizon just decided out of the fucking blue too.
Um,
I dunno,
just
okay.
Put some sort of block on the thing so I wouldn't get some sort of extra
charges,
which I had already resigned myself to getting.
I'm just like,
fuck it.
I'm not getting the plan.
I'm up here for three,
four days.
I'll have a big cell phone bill.
What do I give a fuck?
I don't give a shit.
You want me to write some numbers on a piece of paper and then you stick it in
the thing and then the numbers show up on the screen.
I mean,
that's how much what money means to me at this fucking point.
It's just like,
why?
What?
What are,
what do you want me to write on the little piece of paper?
Who gives a fuck and we put a smiley face in the Zeros.
That's all we're doing.
Okay.
None of us has anything of value.
We just got a bunch of stuff in a fucking hell out.
Jesus.
Bill,
you're going down this road.
I am.
I am going down this road.
How many people do you know have anything?
A fucking piece of silver,
some gold,
whatever.
It happened to us.
We used to be gentlemen,
right?
I went,
you stayed home.
We rode around on a donkey with a curly cued mustaches.
We had a little Satchel,
a fucking gold or some shit.
Right?
Then some bandits would come along and they take it from you,
right?
All dressed in green with the fucking,
you know,
leotards on all that Robin Hood Shit.
Right.
Then there was some brought up in the tower.
All of that is gone.
It's all gone.
No.
Now you work all week.
They give you a little piece of paper.
It's got some numbers on it.
You stick it into the ATM and then the numbers show up.
Right.
Goes,
hey,
you owe me some money.
I'll write,
I'll write some numbers on a piece of paper.
You Go,
thank you.
You know,
it all works until it doesn't.
And then what do you get?
He is going to have you,
you're not gonna have anything.
So anyways.
Yeah.
So I don't give a fuck.
And what,
what do you have any big cell phone bill?
What do I give a shit?
If it's more numbers on a piece of paper,
it's,
it's not
better.
I guess at the end of the day is worth something.
But I,
I just,
I don't give a shit about a high cell phone bill and I don't give a shit about
sky miles.
I just don't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
You don't like when you have some miles with somebody and they go,
oh,
you're,
you better use these,
you better use or they're going to expire.
I always call them up.
You say,
yeah,
I want you to know you can keep them.
I don't need your fucking miles.
Or I take them now,
I don't give a shit.
Stop threatening me with your stupid fucking miles by now.
If I need a plane ticket,
I'll buy one.
Anything to not have to go into your fucking website and figure out where I can
fly with my so called free miles already paid for it.
They're not free.
You can't,
Oh God,
I'm in a mood.
So anyways,
so my phone didn't fucking work,
so when I was,
so I went up there and they put a block on it so I wouldn't,
I have to write a bigger number on a piece of paper and send it to them so they
can stick it in their ATM machine.
And,
uh,
when I came back,
it was still blocked.
So I went over to the Verizon place,
turned out the person who helped me out was a fucking lesson.
Right.
And he's trying to help me fix the phone and what's killing me is his company
did the thing to my phone that's now made my phone fucked up and they can't
figure out how to undo it.
And,
uh,
you know,
I tried as long as I could to keep my cool.
I didn't flip out that,
but I dropped a couple f bombs.
I'm glad he told me that,
you know,
he was a listener of the podcast because,
if he didn't say that,
then I just would have been,
you know,
I wouldn't have been on my best behavior and I would have said fuck a lot more.
Um,
it took me two trips over there because then they were like,
all right,
well I think we fixed it.
This is like an hour later.
I think we fixed it and a,
it should,
you know,
reboot by tomorrow morning.
So I was like,
I find,
you know,
I get back to the office,
I can't fucking,
you know,
I go to text my lovely wife,
it's not going through.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
So I said,
well maybe I'll call her cause I wanted to take the,
uh,
the capital's against the fucking fly.
I wanted her to take the game,
you know,
and uh,
I went to call up and it just,
I called her number and it just goes a welcome to Verizon.
Please enter your last four digits of your social security number.
Please enter this by pressing one.
You agree to a two year contract with Verizon.
If you come out early,
we will yellow.
It's upon.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
So I,
uh,
he had ended up having to go back to the fucking place and um,
this other guy got on it.
He figured out what the fuck was wrong with it.
So now my phone is fine.
So I've just,
I've had one of those fucking day.
So when I was in there I was just thinking,
you know,
and I was just like,
my can't listen to my music.
And they were like,
oh that's cause it's on the cloud.
And I was like,
I never wanted to be on the cloud.
I don't want to be on that fucking thing.
I don't want you guys seeing what the fuck I'm doing.
Leave me alone.
I keep opting out of that fucking thing.
But every time I reboot my phone,
it just fucking automatically starts back up or some shit.
You fucking nosy.
Nerdy cunts.
Okay.
They always sit like act on like to do when you were fucking favor.
You know,
someone was telling me that,
that that shit about them sharing your private information.
I,
which I've said the entire fucking time,
that day should get your permission first.
And certainly if they go and resell it,
you ought to get a cut of it.
Right.
I mean it's your personal information too.
They act as a broker of chance.
You get a fee,
I guess that's in the US,
the Supreme Court.
That's what somebody told me.
It wasn't a lawyer and I can't even remember who it was.
Um,
so anyways,
so as I'm sitting there,
uh,
his time,
it's,
Time's going by.
I started looking at the flip phones and I was like,
Oh man,
I love these things.
Flip loans were great,
you know,
a little fucking size of a hockey but not even the size of a hockey puck right
in your pocket.
You know what I mean?
Bullet kill me was they all had a camera on them,
which I don't fucking like,
and I didn't have time to ask.
The guy wasn't with you just have a flip phone that has no fucking camera on it
and maybe I'll go back to this and I asked the other guy asked the other guy,
these are all young guys,
right?
Born in the 90s,
So I'm like,
do they still sell iPods?
And he's like,
yeah,
the apple store best buy or whatever.
So I say,
fuck it.
I'll just put all my music on the fucking my iPod,
right.
And then I'll just get one of these flip phones.
And I was really trying to think what the fuck I would be missing out on.
It would take me longer to text,
but pictures wouldn't be as good.
Who gives a fuck?
My video wouldn't be as good.
Who gives a fuck and a,
you know what the deal breaker was?
The GPS system.
I don't want to go back to having a Tom.
I still have a Thomas Guide,
my fucking Prius.
I don't want to have to go back to look it up.
Shit.
I mean,
as much as I would like to use my brain to do that again,
out of all the things that they've made easier,
um,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I got to give it up as much as,
as,
as a curmudgeon that I am the,
uh,
the fucking thing telling you where to go is great.
You know,
even though I probably already bitched about it on the podcast and that was sort
of the deal breaker.
I was like,
well,
I got,
I got to have one of those.
Right.
I at least got to have that.
I don't want to go back to looking at fucking maps and Shit,
you know?
Although I could figure it out,
most of it,
I dunno.
I think what it would end up happening is not the social aspect of it would be
the business aspect.
I don't do the Uber thing,
so I wouldn't be missing out on that.
And I don't fucking order food that way,
do I?
No,
I don't,
I don't even know what the fuck I have it flow.
Is it still a podcast is just me?
Just fucking,
well,
I've always babbled anyways.
Um,
yeah,
I've had a fucking brutal week,
man.
I lost my fucking shit.
Like my temper as never been worse.
It's never worse.
I need to,
I need to fucking relax.
Okay.
Um,
I was working all day and all I wanted was some spaghetti and meatballs.
I got this fucking Italian joint.
They make the homemade noodles,
the meatballs.
A fucking damn good,
you know,
and I just wear a craving for it.
I'm like,
I'm fucking getting that right.
So I get home and I say to my lovely wife,
I go,
Hey,
can you,
can you fucking hit the APP thing that gets the person to go pick up your food?
And we'll once again,
you know,
I once again have faith that this person outside of the food industry is not
going to do anything to this food.
You know?
Have you seen that thing?
The guy in the fucking elevator eating some shit off the top of the pizza.
And of course we call the restaurant.
They don't do it.
Postmate it can you postmate the fucking thing and they're like,
oh,
we don't do that over here.
We're a real restaurant.
So like,
all right,
well before we put in the order,
my wife wanted some white fish.
I'm going to get to spaghetti.
So I fucking drive over there and jammed pack with people.
I'd go,
yeah,
hey,
a pickup order.
She goes,
oh,
is that Fenin spaghetti in a white fish?
I was like,
yeah,
it was.
She's like,
oh,
we ran out of fish.
Okay,
so I didn't put it in.
Did you still want this spaghetti?
Yep.
And I swear to God,
man.
Okay.
I'd just like we fucking call 10 minutes ago,
it took you 10 minutes to figure out you're out of fish.
I just said,
you know what,
hang on a second.
Because I knew I was going to snap and I just walked out of the restaurant and
the second I got outside I just started cock sucking motherfucker.
The fuck is to take the fucking Goddamn fucking forget.
Just slipping out.
Right?
Wasn't screaming,
just cock sucking that type of shit right.
Far Away.
You'd think I was speaking German,
fascist cock sucking motherfucker.
Right.
And I heard these two people,
those people are eating outside.
They started laughing at me,
right?
And I didn't give a shit and I just kept my fucking and then got my Prius and
just glided away.
Just
made a complete and utter fucking fool of myself.
Complete and utter fucking fool of myself.
And um,
you know,
I go to these great periods.
It's almost like my cigar smoke and just go through these great periods where
I'm just not,
I got an under control.
I got it under control and then it just slowly,
you know,
spins out of control.
And right now,
you know,
I'm not smoking a lot.
I'm drinking a little bit,
but nothing crazy.
I think I have everything under control and just something has to,
something's got to give.
You know what I mean?
It's like he'd give up smoking,
eat like a fucking pig,
you know?
I don't know.
You start working out.
There's always something.
Just got to balance it out.
I've used these fucking people that are nothing but
do gooders I mean,
I don't know.
Maybe they'll robots.
I don't know what,
what they are or maybe they just never exposed themselves to fun shit.
But for the love of God,
I can't do it.
I cannot 100% just be a decent human being.
I don't think it's a,
I don't think it's possible.
I have too much free time.
Maybe that's what it is.
Well,
maybe I'm just a piece of shit and I'm looking for an excuse.
I don't fucking know.
But,
um,
anyways,
I haven't been able to work out as much as I want to.
I think that Burns off a lot of the bullshit.
But uh,
anyways,
speaking of which,
the gym,
the gym's getting a,
I get the floor put in Friday.
It's a three day process.
It's a poxy floor.
It's sort of the,
uh,
they call it a lab.
The lava flow.
It's,
it's really fucking cool looking or it's going to look out of style and fucking
three days.
I don't know what,
but uh,
I did go with the gray was sort of a black,
black and tinge to it,
so I Nice muted fucking color and uh,
Nia told me to get a mirror in there,
you know,
cause she wants to look at her form when she's doing whatever the hell she's
doing.
I don't know what she's going to be doing.
She wants to look at a form.
I don't use gyms for my form.
I just mirrors,
I'm should say I never used those for my form.
I wait until after I'm done lifting.
And then I used a marriage of flection.
I just walk over and go,
you're right.
That's all I use it for.
Why?
There's always does going to be a lot of breadth marks on my,
uh,
my fucking mirror.
Um,
I can't fucking wait.
And,
um,
so my goal is every day before work,
this thing I'm working on that I'm not allowed to talk about,
um,
is I'm going to work out in the morning,
take my dog for a hike,
I'm going to work out in the morning,
and then I'm going to put in a solid fucking day.
And at the end of the day,
I'm going to come home.
Daddy's going to have a little Bingo Bango and I'm going to talk to my lovely
wife and I'm going to go to bed.
That's what my life's going to be like.
Um,
that is the goal.
Anyways.
You know.
So this contractor that I have working on this thing,
yeah.
Unlike my last one is a fucking guys,
right.
As ranked.
So,
uh,
it's been,
it's been a fucking wonderful thing.
However,
let's stop talking about this bullshit.
All right.
Um,
how about the fucking NHL playoffs?
Playoffs.
Oh,
first of all,
congratulations to the Golden State Warriors.
73 fucking wins.
73 and nine.
I got to tell you,
I don't know.
It took 20 years for someone to beat 72.
Do you think somebody ever beats,
I mean they had single digit loss for the season.
That's fucking unbelievable.
That's,
that's about as borderline on Bree.
I think that that really,
um,
well,
you know,
so I don't know enough about who Paul,
who had,
who had the record before the bowls,
like how long those records last.
I'm 73 and nine.
That's,
that's going to be a tough one if basically the not even the 96 bulls won that
many fucking games.
Um,
but I,
you know,
those guys,
if you had that carrot dangling in front of them,
they'd somehow fucking figured out how to win 70.
If somebodies got to go 74 and eight,
I don't know that you can do that.
Um,
and I don't know that I know all the rules of basketball either.
So take that with a giant grain of salt.
MMM.
Congratulations to them.
And congratulations to Colby Bryant Hall of fame career,
going out with 60 points on 50 shots,
which I thought was perfect.
You never considered your teammates your entire career.
Why would you do it on your last night?
Okay.
Was perfect way you went out.
And I love that Nike Commercial,
the Nike commercial where he stands in the middle of the court and the Celtic
fans,
really an actor in Celtic gear gets up and start singing to him.
I just,
and all the fans around the league or singing how they hate them,
but they really love him and respect him.
And there's no other teammates knowing the Lakers.
No fucking nod to the past and fucking magic.
And Kareem,
no thanks Phil Jackson.
No nothing.
Just Colby standing in the middle of the court in the fucking Christ pose with
this fucking arms out.
And it was absolutely fucking perfect.
Great job.
Nike.
Great fucking job.
MMM.
One of the greatest one-on-one fucking players you're ever going to see.
One of the greatest outside shooters you ever going to see?
Uh,
one of the biggest cancers in a locker room that ever fucking existed more.
He was sort of the second coming of Wilt Chamberlain as far as the stuck points
that he scored versus what the fuck he did in the locker room.
And
I just thought it was fucking party took 50 fucking shots.
Ah,
I don't think it could have been any more perfect.
That was just,
it was phenomenal and it was,
that is Colby takes 50 shots.
He had noise.
You Buddy score 60 points.
You know what I mean?
I honestly think that I could've played on a lot of those Laker teams because
he,
you know,
he's not going to throw it to you anyways.
I could have run up down the court,
my fucking pasty legs.
How bad would my pasty thighs look in those fucking golden uniforms?
Ugh.
Unbelievable.
Or even worse than when they had those white ones there for awhile.
The home white ones,
it just be like,
I dunno,
you'd have that little bit of fringe to kind of bring it to at the end of it to
break up the shorts and my fucking milk size and then maybe I had some socks so
I don't fuck,
I don't know.
Chase is the,
even that vision is fucking disturbing to make.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
let me do a little bit of a little bit of advertising here as I'm checking in on
you and this lovely fucking day.
I'm taping the fucking fliers and capital's right now.
Um,
what do we got here?
Oh,
Jesus club.
Dobby,
Everybody Club Gab club.
Debbie,
your daddy loves jazz club w AH,
if you're anything like me,
then you know exactly what you like and how you like it except what you're in
the wine aisle.
Tannins and terrariums.
I don't know how to say any of these means.
Nothing to you unless you happen to be a fancy pants professional.
Some of the uh,
um,
please include all the following points.
Absolutely.
All right.
Well with club [inaudible] Club,
Debbie,
you out blow West Bend your,
the guessing game is over.
Clubbed.
Dubby I got all my big boy pants.
Uh,
is the world's only personalized wine club and your wines are sent directly to
your door.
Uh,
not only does club w and you talk a bill send you wine,
they send you wine that you'll love drinking.
That's because club and tear looking for some weapons of mass destruction.
Easy to use.
Six question quiz figures out your palate so that every bottle you receive is
perfectly tailored to your tastes.
Glib.
Debbie used to be an alcoholic.
Now I speak Spanish is leading the great to glass wine revolution.
They work directly with the vineyards to cut out the middleman,
which saves you some Dinero Club,
Debbie,
and running out of references and go down to get more.
Uh,
even offers a no risk guarantee that you'll love what they'll send you or your
money back.
Call to action right now.
It Club W and my dad was a war hero is offering my listeners 50% off your first
order when you go to club dubby.com/birth wine should be fun.
Not Pretentious.
Well,
you don't need to dumb it down either.
I think he should have,
you know,
wine isn't that difficult,
is it?
It's a little intimidating.
Start learning as you drink it.
Club Debbie a.com/ [inaudible] you even get 50% off your first order.
That's club w.
Dot com slash burr.
All right,
two more.
Everybody tracker or as I say,
trap smart cast SMAD phones,
smart homes.
Technology has made everything smart,
but losing your stuff stills still make smart people feel really stupid dude.
He's fucking wicked stupid track makes losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is a coin size device that locates misplaced keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
anything in seconds just paired to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and it finds its precise location with the tap of a
button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone,
press the button on track and your phone rings even when it's on silent.
How fucking creepy is that with over 1.5 million devices tracker has the largest
crowd gps network in the world.
World.
World,
world,
yeah,
yeah.
So you're lost items show up on the map.
Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything.
Again with fucking tracking listeners to this show,
get a special discount offer of 40% off your first tracker device.
Go to tracker.com and enter the code [inaudible] the hardest thing you'll ever
have to fight it yet is there.
Go to track a.com right now and enter the Promo Code [inaudible] for 40% off.
Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code [inaudible].
All right.
Elyx Helix.
Is it the band?
What is it?
Uh,
what is it about buying a mattress that makes you feel in all Skatey and
violated?
Is it the pushy salespeople?
Is that the homeless guy who just walked in off the street and rolled his head
around the pillows,
the fake President Day sale or the fact that you know,
you'll regret what you bought as you do the walk of shame out of the mattress
store?
Well,
what happened in there?
Huh?
Uh,
those days are over.
Thanks to hell x or he looks sleep where you can buy a mattress online,
customized for you for hundreds of dollars instead of thousands.
Well,
how do you test it out?
Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions I hear it is,
this is how you test it out by answering a few simple questions and he always
creates your custom sleep profile,
the build you the perfect mattress,
the results.
Our customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep.
I'd love to read this questionnaire.
Do you pleasure yourself at what time of day?
Um,
do you feel like you want to feel like there's a foot and your back as you're
rubbing one out?
Uh,
your mattress firm will arrive at your door in about a week and shipping is 100%
free,
uh,
free.
You have a hundred a hundred nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free and give you 100% refund.
Good Lord.
What the fuck did they do with that mattress?
No questions asked.
It's like it never happened.
Oh my God.
And it goes,
where does it go?
Go somewhere to the South Pacific.
If you do love your new Hilux Mac mattress,
keep it and,
and your dignity.
That's why everyone in Gq magazine or what they do with the mattress,
they ship it back and whoever made the thing in the sweatshop gets executed and
then they fall onto the mattress and they fold them up and throw them in the
ocean.
That's what's really going on behind the seats.
If you do love your new helix mattress,
keep it and your and your dignity.
That's why everyone from Gq magazines to Forbes,
they're all talking about Helux or he likes sleep.
Oh,
it's not because you're paying them too.
That's why I'm talking about go to helix.com/ [inaudible] and get $50 off your
order.
That's helix sleep.com/burr.
He likes sleep.com/bar all right,
that's it for that bullshit.
Um,
what am I going to have left here?
23 more fucking minutes.
Oh,
I was driving home today.
Bududa Lou dude,
and somebody in front of me was smoking a cigar and I had my phone,
my head,
my window down just a little bit.
This is how much this habit has me.
I was like,
oh my God.
And I rolled it all the way down.
I was like,
yeah,
go ahead,
dog sticks a 10 out the window or ace Ventura.
That's what I was doing,
driver behind the guy and I was trying to figure it and I drove up next to him
going like,
wow,
the fun guy smoking a cigar and that nice car,
that's some old school shit.
And they pulled up and it wasn't him and um,
I couldn't,
you know,
I couldn't figure out who was smoking the cigar and I realized that cigar smoke
is so fucking stinky.
It could have literally just been like three people smoking on a porch and I
drove by and God damn it,
I miss it.
I Dunno if this is a good idea,
you guys,
this whole fucking two cigars a month because this is like when I try to go easy
with the booze and you know,
when I go,
when I tried to take long periods of time off from boozing,
it doesn't make me go,
you know what?
I don't think,
I don't think I miss drinking.
I don't ever need to drink again.
What?
It makes me feel like is,
you know,
I would like to drink a case of beer by myself and see if I can finish a fifth
object Jack annual.
That's what it makes me feel like.
So I think I need to feed the beast a little bit.
Um,
having said that,
until I drove her home behind the person smoking that unbelievably wonderful
smelling cigar,
I um,
I was actually going like,
you know what?
I think I can make it to my birthday,
which is in June.
And if I didn't do that then I would be how many?
I smoked this year too,
for six and a half.
Six and a half.
Cause won't when I smoked half and it wasn't smoking well,
so we,
I still count that one.
So six and a half.
That would be June and I would be looking at like,
I'd smoked about one a month.
Right.
I think that'd be all right.
I think that would be okay.
You know,
actually in reality,
couldn't you just do heroin once a month if he just did heroin once a month,
12 times a fucking year?
If he didn't do it 12 days in a row,
six days in a row.
So it didn't get you,
you just did it.
That's what they ought to have.
They ought to just have like the heroin spot,
right?
And you got to fucking punch card.
There's no way to falsify it.
No way to sell somebody else's or whatever.
And just once a month,
like what you try it just to see what it was like.
If there was just fucking heroin,
you could go,
you could fucking try it and no matter how bad and if you just like,
I just wanted to do it once just to see what it felt like.
And then you just walk away and you never do it again.
Or if like you can't,
you liked it.
Right?
Which why wouldn't ya?
I heard it's like the greatest feeling ever.
Right?
Why if they,
if they fucking managed it for you,
he just had that fucking itch and there was just nothing you could do about it.
And then once a month you go and you shoot up,
it's fucking awesome.
And everybody can be excited,
like coming up,
you know?
And,
and they have like a,
like a,
every,
the beginning of every month they'd have like a Raffle,
right?
Like,
like,
um,
what do you call it?
The lottery.
And instead of like nine balls coming out,
it's just one ball.
Right.
And it just comes out,
right?
It comes out our right month.
April,
heroin day.
Yes.
The seventeeth seventh that was like,
ah,
fuck 17 died.
The everybody does smack on the 17th.
Except for people that,
you know,
got to keep like reactor's going and shit like that.
They get to do it on like the 18th provided this someone then some would be hung
over from heroin or whatever the fuck he can.
I don't know.
We'd have to work that out.
Catchers have heroin one day,
you don't,
once a week,
everybody just gets fucked up.
And you can opt out,
right?
Once a month you do heroin and then you have like,
you know,
booze and days.
It's gotta be a way to do it.
Well,
the government just becomes a big fucking drug dealing babysitter now.
But the Hue,
imagine the fucking lines in.
If everybody's got a good head that doesn't work.
I guess you got to manage it yourself.
I guess that is the problem.
You know the government won't step in that.
You know what?
They can't collect enough money off of these super rich fucking people.
That's what it is.
They get the money outside the country and then you've got too many other people
sitting around their sweatpants and they don't want to fucking work,
you know,
and then fucking,
regular people,
regular people like us write down the fucking metal.
I'm going to say everybody listen to this podcast is regular somewhere.
Somewhere right in the middle,
Huh?
Pay In taxes out the fucking ass,
aren't ya?
Ah,
Shane's.
You get heroin once a month,
once a month.
The heroin store,
that's what they should do for the middle class is getting squeezed out.
You just once a month,
they shoot you up once every couple of months.
You get to decide,
but no more than once a month.
You know,
you do it on a say,
right?
You're just fucking nod off and that's it.
One night's fucking dose.
And then I don't know what you shiver and shake a little bit.
Eat some fucking Jeb one dose.
She not going to get hooked on you.
You know what?
I got to look this up.
Heroin once a month.
Hey,
little girl,
do some heroin once a fucking month.
I don't think you'll get addicted.
I always spelled this wrong,
by the way.
No e on it.
No heroes here.
Heroin once a month.
Yeah.
Heroin Rehab,
treatment opinions.
Can the use of heroin be casual?
This is the beginning of a life changing decision right here.
Can you use heroin?
Okay.
You know,
and all of us too.
It's a chat room.
Okay?
It seems from all government propaganda,
don't we love it?
And most threads and discussions here on whatever this is that heroin is for
addicts and junkies.
Is it the case that one can take heroin for a one time experiment slash
experience in order to witness the effects?
Uh,
please share.
Um,
that's not a good word to use in a heroin chat room off.
Please share experiences with each,
with one time users versus long time.
All right?
Yes,
there are people who will use heroin once or a few times and will not return to
it.
Usually it takes two or more tries to really enjoy it.
First time users usually feel a bit nauseous or used tobacco in the day this was
smoking.
This means you will not be a fuck you.
Fuck you.
You're just some regular person.
I want a doctor,
uh,
answers.
Let's go to answers.yahoo.com.
Come on.
Come on,
load.
There we go.
Is it,
can you use heroin one time a best answer capitol?
No,
not at all.
I'm a retired heroin dealer.
I know what happened to my customers when they tried to only use it casually
when they were partying.
They became addicted.
Their lives became miserable.
A lot of them ended up homeless in jail,
losing jobs,
flunking out of college.
While I profited off them.
Let's see if that comes in here and any other bad luck he could think of.
Their families ended up being prostitutes.
Heroin use is completely miserable life and there's no way to use it
responsibly.
People can become addicted to heroin the first time they use it and try it,
Yada,
Yada.
This other person said,
it's very,
very unlikely.
I'm a foreign heroin addict who's in a Methadone program right now and you're in
a chat room.
Fucking multitasking.
Now the person,
it may be possible for some personalities.
Is it worth the risk?
What is the benefit to gain?
Somebody says,
don't know,
go roll up a fatty.
What was that movie where Alan are,
could just started using heroin when he was like 80.
If I were to shoot heroin once a week for the rest of my life.
I see here,
this is on reddit.
This is the last one.
Hypothetical,
of course.
Never done it.
A Blah,
blah,
blah.
I'm interested in the effects.
Suppose I shut up a purely and safe,
safely measured dose every Friday.
Where would you get that from?
A drug dealer.
I mean,
it's not regulated.
All right.
You know what?
This is probably one of the dumbest questions I've ever asked and mercifully the
half hour is over.
Um,
so don't do it.
People.
I ain't know shit that I've never heard the expression recreational heroin,
heroin user,
although God knows somebody who's going to write in and claim that they could do
it.
So you know what more power to you,
but I would never fuck with that.
Anyways,
this has been the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in audio.
Um,
please enjoy the music.
And uh,
then I dunno,
we got some classic kits from Monday morning.
Podcasts gone by.
Have a great weekend.
You Con uh,
congratulations to the penguins one in their first one.
Congratulations to the Saint Louis Blues.
May Be in Saint Louis.
Louis make pay at the fair.
Remember that one.
Don't tell me the lights are shaded in every place
there.
We there
could change something like that.
You will be my something or do g and meet me in St Louis.
Louis meet me at the fair.
That's what you did back in the day.
You met some woman's said,
hey,
you know,
I love your dress down to your ankles and your giant hat.
Why don't you meet me in St Louis Louis and meet me?
At the fair,
she'd be like,
why on earth are we going to do that?
And you're like,
cause we gonna fuck.
'Em All right,
that's the podcast.
I have a great weekend.
Your coach,
I'll talk to you on Monday,
right
Joe?
Hey,
what's going on the Monday morning?
And I'm doing it on Tuesday because
I did one yesterday and I was in the,
I was in an airport again and a,
and just suck.
That's what happened.
It started off good.
You know what I mean?
And then it was like evil Knievel when he was jumping the snake river,
you know,
and they fucking,
they let them off,
you know,
and he went across,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
he's going to make it the past.
She came out and he just fucking went straight down.
So that's what happened.
He went right into the fucking river and somehow all he got was a bloody nose.
Um,
that's what happened to me yesterday.
I went to do the podcast,
um,
as I was waiting to get on my jet blue flight,
exit row is all set,
everything was great.
And,
uh,
you know,
all of a sudden they said that we were switching planes.
We had to get off the fucking plane.
That's what happened.
Then I was in the terminal and then I was pissing in an airport again.
And how many have I done that on my podcast?
Oh,
I'm bill Burr,
I'm in an airport.
I'm not happy.
You know what I mean?
Did he really want to fucking hear that story again?
And a saas getting self conscious about that.
That's what happened.
Now that that's the real thing.
Then I got self conscious about it,
which made me lose my train of thought and the whole thing lost it's fucking
momentum in the whole podcast.
Went right down to the snake river and that's what happened.
Okay.
And my nose is bleeding on the plane and everybody thought I was doing coke and
I was trying to say that I wasn't.
And then the stewardess was just like,
is there a problem sir?
Is there a problem?
You know,
she waived the Patriot Act in my face.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
uh,
this bill Burroughs I mentioned at the top of the poor,
cursed,
um,
it's,
you're new to my page.
I do one of these every single Monday.
All right.
And I have to think that somebody is new to my page because a,
I had my big fancy special,
uh,
Sunday night.
Why do I do this on comedy central?
And if I had half a brain,
I could give you some times as to when it's going to be replaying again,
which of course,
I don't know.
But,
um,
I watched three seconds of it cause I can't stand looking at myself.
And I thought it looked fucking awesome and,
uh,
I was happy with it and I want to,
before I get into my bitch and for the week and all that shit,
which I really can't because I'm a really happy about my special,
so there won't be a lot of bitching.
I shouldn't have said that because then,
you know,
by the end of this thing will be fucking bitching about something.
But,
um,
I just want to thank everybody who,
uh,
sent me emails telling me how much they liked it.
Uh,
uh,
that really means a lot to me.
And I got to tell you something,
man,
I don't know about other comics,
but I freak right before those things come out.
You know what I mean?
I sit there thinking like,
oh my God,
what if everybody thinks it sucks?
And I'm like,
no,
I'll do it.
It's good.
Right?
You liked it.
You saw it.
And I know have a little,
what if,
what if people are fucking,
I stopped playing that mental tenants,
you know,
as I'm standing in a Blimpie or a subway,
trying to think what kind of bread I want to get when it's really all the same
kind of fucking bread.
I like how they got that little fucking little oven.
They're like,
they're like,
it's the old country,
like you're in Europe.
Oh Wow.
And they're baking bread there and say,
ah,
it's just such a fucking scam.
Look at me.
I'm already pitching now.
Let's keep it happy.
Keep it happy.
So yeah.
So basically,
yeah,
it was kind of freaking,
you know,
you want people to like what you do.
And,
uh,
if I liked who I was as a person and I was comfortable with myself,
I would have no need to get on a stage and act like a jackass for a fucking hour
for other people's approval that I've never even met.
Okay.
So they go,
so that,
so anybody who was going to ask me that question like,
do,
do you live free or die?
Right.
The four,
you have like a special coming out,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like totally rolling on the floor,
laughing my ass off.
Uh,
yes.
Yes I do.
I do like totally fucking freak out.
Um,
all right.
Okay.
So anyways,
before I get going here with the podcast,
which is a day late and hopefully not a dollar short,
I apologize to all my regular listeners,
all 14.
Are you?
Um,
you know,
it stops.
I got a bunch of friend requests and I thought I was finally going to be able to
get up past fucking 28,000 and I added everybody and I was 28,992 I wanted to
get to 29,000.
Got Damn.
Man,
I swear to God,
there's a fucking conspiracy here and you know it is.
It's the fucking Rothschild's family and they're all over Facebook and I'm
telling you that's the scam.
That's the new scam and it's time few people to fucking wake up and realize
that's your social networking.
Internet rights and freedoms are being taken away from you.
I'm Joe Biden.
You know,
I don't even know who Joe Biden is.
I've just been hearing his name in the background,
kind of like,
he's like the Jonas brothers and my cultural worlds.
Like every time I walk by a magazine,
it's either his face or the Jonas brothers and I don't know either one of their
material at the Jonas brothers started,
started singing a speech of Joe Biden and you told me that that was a number one
hit and teenage girls loved it.
I'd have to agree with you.
Those Jonas brothers,
it really wear tight clothes,
don't they?
Is that what the hair is so curly.
Thank you.
Oh right.
There's one for you and his little monologue joke for you.
They really do.
They just look really chunky,
like they're going to be fat fucks when they get older.
You know what I mean?
Which be hilarious.
Not like they going to be obese,
but they're going to have that fat middle aged face.
And that's the big thing that nobody talks about when you get middle age like
me,
is trying not to have a fat porky pig face.
It's the weirdest thing.
Even if you're in shape,
you still get that,
that fucking swollen head,
the cheek,
she get the Winston Churchill face,
you know jolly.
You get the jolly rosy cheeks.
You know what it is?
It's the booze man.
It's the fucking booze,
which I have laid off for a about two and a half weeks.
I've had a beer and a half at a half a beer at a,
uh,
the uninformed taping that I did with Joe to Rosa,
my XM radio show.
I had half a beer at that.
And let me tell you something.
And you stopped drinking beer for two weeks and you drink,
you take a sip of a beer.
Uh,
it's one of the greatest things you've ever tasted in your life.
It's delicious.
Like you ever watch Shawshank redemption and not Tim Robbins when he's sitting
on the roof and he gives that,
that Conti fucking gorilla maniac guard tax advice and all he wants is some suds
as he talks about.
He talks about just the way he described sitting on that roof.
I guess it's Morgan Freeman's character describes drinking that beer that always
makes me want to drink a fucking beer.
You know,
just drink a 12 pack.
There is a fucking fly in my apartment that he doesn't realize it,
but his life is ending today.
You know what I mean?
I hate being like that,
you know?
I know it's just the fucking insect and shit and you know,
you kill this and then all of a sudden the bees start dropping off.
But he's,
he's fucking obnoxious.
You don't want to have a house fly in and spending your house for a couple of
days.
You know,
he started,
you know,
he's kind of like an athlete and the toilet twilight of his career.
It's like Brett Farve and the jets.
You know it's exactly that motherfucker sitting right.
Then let's try to kill,
this is the first time I ever tried to kill a sly right on my podcast and see on
the inside.
This is a big thing.
You don't know if this is it on the inside or the outside.
All right,
one,
two,
three.
Okay,
motherfucker.
I got you.
Bam.
Right between the blinds.
There you go.
So someday when he insects takeover this podcast as this is what's going to take
me down,
then I'll try to be like,
no,
that wasn't me.
That was somebody else.
I sold my act and my brother just like that Guy Gallagher.
I sold the podcast to him,
Bill Burr,
part two when he was doing it all,
I was fucking satisfying all.
It'll be hilarious to,
somebody actually sent me a complaint.
Can somebody send me an email complaining about the fact that I just murdered an
insect mocking those fucking Peter Maniacs.
You know what I'm saying?
And I love animals too,
but I just hate groups.
I hate groups of people because in order to get noticed,
they just make a lot of noise and they never come up with a good chant.
And it's just,
I don't know,
it's just fucking annoying to knowing and they gotta do they gotta try to be
shocking,
you know,
like,
it really sucks.
And there's those commercials that they make about cigarettes.
Have you seen that?
They always do some public demonstration.
I don't know what the fuck the name of those commercials are,
but they're so fucking annoying that he,
they just,
uh,
they make me want to smoke.
Just I wouldn't smoke,
but you know what I mean?
I can't even explain it.
It's just like,
you know,
they make me want to do something and I don't even want to fucking do.
All right.
Whatever.
I got you guys get the point.
All right.
Whatever.
It's early.
Let me just send me a text message.
Joe.
Nick comedian out of,
uh,
San Francisco via fucking,
Pittsburgh said,
uh,
we went to the of Ucla Bruin game last night.
That's another reason why I didn't do the podcast cause I got off the plane,
I got off the plane over there mang and a Chichi,
get the yellow and I uh,
went right over to the rose bowl and I went to Ucla,
Tennessee,
Tennessee game.
Fucking unbelievable game.
Went into overtime and a UCLA one it,
and I think I have a team out here.
I was,
I got so fucking into that game.
I'm tie something.
If you guys,
if you're into pro sports,
take a second look at college football and all everybody's psyched about the NFL
dude.
It's fucking bananas.
It's unbelievable.
Can I just say bananas?
What Dosha?
I just really hate myself sometimes.
It's fucking bananas.
It's wacky.
Bananas.
You know,
I just made myself sound like I go to games with one of those raccoon coats from
the 1920s.
Rah Rah sis boom by.
Um,
but no,
it's insane.
You know,
you got like the band's going crazy.
The students are going crazy.
They got all those chants and stuff.
It's the closest thing America has to like a,
you have a like watch those.
Those are some of the,
the soccer or football as they call it,
over in England where people are just going bananas.
Uh,
I said bananas again.
Jesus is quite,
if I say it one more time,
I'm going to have to hang up on myself.
When the fuck did I start saying bananas?
You know what that's on my friends and everyone around me in my life,
but not saying,
dude,
why the fuck do you say that?
You really need to stop saying that.
It's like some of my relatives in Boston and who say Pissa.
You see that game,
dude?
Yeah,
dude,
it was Pissa like fucking in their 40 still saying that.
It's just,
it makes me fucking skin crawl,
but then I'm saying bananas.
All right.
But anyways,
I'm into college football.
I'm actually,
I'm doing a gig coming up in Austin,
Texas,
and I'm going to a Texas longhorn Missouri game.
I'm going to be there.
So if you're one of the hundred thousand fucking maniacs who were there going
nuts rather than bananas,
what's a good way to say bananas?
There's my podcast question for you.
All right.
And speaking of podcast questions,
there's a segue for you.
Um,
we're gonna get into the podcast questions,
but first a moment from our sponsor.
Last week I talked about a state capitals.
Um,
did you miss that episode?
Well,
maybe she'll listen to that half hour babbling and,
uh,
I was kind of asking the question is,
why the fuck is it always the second rate?
City always seems to be the capital,
you know what I mean?
Like it's never,
uh,
you know,
New York,
it's not New York City.
That's what you'd think it would be.
But it's Albany.
Okay.
It's,
you go to Illinois,
it's not Chicago,
it's Springfield.
You go to Pennsylvania,
it's not Philly of Pittsburgh,
it's Harrisburg.
It's always some like what the fuck?
You know?
And I thought it was,
cause people initially thought that that was the town that was going to be the
shit.
And uh,
then it stopped being the shit in another town became the shit,
but they already made it be the capitol and they were too embarrassed to say
that they made a mistake.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like the people like the Jonas brothers right now,
you know the Jonas brothers are the musical equivalent to the city of Albany.
That's what I'm trying,
that's what I'm trying to say there.
Um,
so anyways,
this guy tries to claim,
he says on the topic of why cities like Harrisburg and almonds,
Albany,
our state capitols over Philly or New York City.
The reason is because most state capitols are located geographically in the
center of the state.
That way local government,
government officials wouldn't have to travel across the whole state to get to
the capital.
There are a few exceptions like Carson city and Tallahassee,
but overall that's the general reason why shit's cities are capitals.
Is that true?
Wait a minute.
Boston,
that's not in the middle of this state is provenance.
Provenance Kinda is.
I Dunno.
Is that true?
I actually got in an argument that guy the other day,
Pete Dominick comedian,
and he goes,
cite your sources.
You need three sources,
just like journalism.
And I realized that not only do I don't not have three sources,
I usually don't even have one.
I just have my gut going in.
It sounds like fucking bullshit.
And then I just spend it so I sound like I know what I'm talking about.
So can anybody back up with that guy saying,
is that the real reason for that?
Huh?
Anybody?
Um,
all right,
that's it.
Let's get into the questions for this week.
The podcast questions.
Question number one.
Hey Bill,
I have a question for your podcast.
Um,
if you were locked,
and this is a great question,
by the way,
this is one of the greatest questions I've,
I've ever gotten.
Okay.
This guy is setting the fucking bar for podcast questions.
All right,
here is the questions.
Here's a question.
Sorry.
If you were locked in a gymnasium full of hundreds of unarmed six-year-olds of
various weight,
height races and temperaments,
and all you had were the clothes on your back,
how many of them do you think you could kill before they overpowered you?
What a fucking great question.
All right,
so obviously I'm setting all morals aside here.
If you set aside all morals and all feelings of guilt and a,
or maybe I just felt like I was right,
like these were evil kids.
I'm trying to think of a reason why a gymnasium full of six year olds of various
weights,
heights and races and temperaments,
how many do I think I could fucking kill before they overpowered me?
Uh,
let's see here.
The average is six year old has got to be about,
are they four feet minute,
four feet tall?
Like fucking Tim Duncan was probably four feet tall when he was six.
And there any future NBA players in this,
if they're not,
if they're just going to be like accountants and fucking,
you know,
occasional wife beater,
that'd be the tough one.
I think,
you know what I'd have to do,
do they know I'm going to overpower me?
I'm just going to have to assume like if they know that I'm coming in there as
the killer of six year olds.
So they all banded together to try to slay me.
I mean,
I think the first thing I'd have to do,
not just not to hack off of,
uh,
ESPN analysts here and use one of their expressions,
but I'm going to have to here.
I think the first thing I'd have to do is I'd have to set the tone and by
setting the tone,
I mean I just have to do something so fucked up to the first wave of Braveheart,
six year olds coming at me that I would have that give those steps.
Second wave,
that split second of thinking about what the fuck they were doing.
Right.
And uh,
I'm talking about leg sweeps,
the kind that would,
that would blow out and adult ACL.
Okay.
Which would I'm talking,
yeah,
I'm wearing timberlands and I'm going to fucking,
I get one of them with one of those,
you know,
you remember that move.
What's his face used to do?
Andre the giant when they throw a dude off the ropes and he just stick his foot
up.
I don't know man.
I don't know.
Fuck,
I don't know how many I could get,
how many I could kill.
I'd have to fuck them up first and leave them days and then I'd have to go back
to finishing them off.
But,
uh,
if I just had to use my fist man,
I mean,
you know,
even though the six year old that's still a skull,
it's going to hurt.
Wow.
I'm getting really creepy with this on.
Okay.
I would say I could probably fuck up.
I could kill about 11
I could kill 11 but you know,
I,
you know what,
you know,
I think that I could go kill a number that low is because number one,
someone to discovery channel,
I saw this wasp entered this,
this beehive of these honeybees and like the wasps in or whatever the fuck it
was can destroy the honeybees.
They can kill like a hundred to one.
They can destroy these fuckers.
So what happened was he went in there,
he was doing surveillance for his,
his wasp or his horn at nest.
And then now he's going to go back and get his boys and they were all going to
come back.
Are you sending out a signal for them to come?
So what he didn't realize was the honeybee som and they started like wiggling
their acids as a signal.
And what happened was,
is that the exact fucking moment,
all the honeybees jumped on the fucking wasp of the horn at the same time.
And they want top of them.
And they started like basically dry humping him.
But what they really were doing,
and they will vibrating.
And I guess a Hornet can only survive in temperatures up to 116 degrees,
where a honeybee can go up to 118 degrees.
So these mother fuckers,
they vibrated to the point where the temperature was 118 degrees,
one degree fucking more away,
117 degrees,
one degree more than the Horner could,
could fucking survive.
And one degree less than what would fucking kill them.
It was,
it was one of the greatest attacks,
the mercy Malaya.
And they basically cook the fucker.
And that was the end him.
So get those six year olds knew I was coming and they all jumped on me and
started fucking vibrating being a redhead.
I mean,
once they got over 80 degrees,
I would be fucked.
I'd be passed out and that would be the end of it.
All they'd have to do is drag my unconscious carcass out into the sun and then
that would be it.
That would be a deaths by third degrees.
Sunburns.
All right,
Jesus.
I'm like,
God bless from answering that one.
Okay,
now we're getting onto overrated,
underrated.
Then I got to get on with my,
uh,
with my day here as to you.
Who's kidding?
Who,
why am I acting like I'm the only busy one?
All right.
For those of you new to my podcast,
last couple of weeks,
people have been sending me in,
uh,
their list of stuff that they think is overrated and underrated.
I'll say as a new Ucla Bruin fan,
you know,
when I find fucking overrated,
the fucking Tennessee volunteers.
What do you think about that?
Ranked 18th against Ucla where they ranked 44th,
the third string quarterback when a Jekyll and Hyde gain the guy too for
pickoffs.
One for a touchdown the first half.
And then he came out in the second half.
Like fucking Joe Montana,
Kurt Warner,
and maybe even Fran Tarkington.
Um,
all right.
You don't actually is overrated is underrated,
is a man's ability to shower,
shave,
and be ready and in the fucking car within 15 minutes.
I experienced that this weekend when Finney brand,
the beloved owner of the Stress Factory in New Jersey took me out on his boat.
Okay.
And we came back,
the show was in an hour and there was some sort of boat house and he's like,
he talks like fucking,
you know,
a muppet.
He's like,
oh,
I got it on there.
I got,
oh I got to take a shower.
Just hang on a second.
He leaves me in the car with his awful fucking Bruce Springsteen CD cause
everybody in New Jersey loves Bruce Springsteen.
So,
uh,
he goes in and I'm thinking,
it's going to be a fuck.
He's going to be in for 25 fucking minutes.
Let's do it in and out came out,
you know,
he looked great,
smelled of man soap and he was fucking ready to go.
He actually make,
made me feel unclean within 10 minutes.
It's an incredible thing.
So that's my overrated,
underrated for the week.
Okay,
here's everybody else's.
Alright.
Overrated Stella bear.
It tastes just like Budweiser and every non tasting having schlepped insist it's
a quality beer.
I guess nobody's heard of Lam.
Lango needas or dog fish head.
You know what?
I've never heard of those either and I can't,
I can't pass judgment on those.
But those sounds like those kinds of beers that I see when I go to Colorado and
there's those,
those rafting hippie,
I'm into Dave Matthews,
Bergen stock,
hackey sack fuckers drinking,
that kind of shit.
You know when you go down there and they have those,
those fucking micro brews.
I think microbrews overrated.
But the best one I did,
I went to was the one I told you Dan on Nantucket.
Cisco Breweries.
Man,
God damn.
And I'm still waiting for my vodka by the way.
You sons of bitches.
I understand your mom and pop.
What the fuck?
I got three bottles at AAA coming my way and I have since quit drinking.
Maybe they listened to the podcast.
All right.
Overrated hyped up bachelor parties.
Oh,
isn't that the truth?
You always think it's going to be like a fucking movie.
This guy says if you have to wear a tee shirt that says something like stick a
fork in them,
it's almost guaranteed that it's going to be a queer fest
especially.
There's definitely going to be at least one dip.
Shit.
That is way too into taking pictures.
I know how gay is that guys can't take pictures.
That's fucking gay wanting something gay about me.
I'm actually in the flowers to a like it's so gay.
It goes beyond gay and comes back a heterosexual I think.
No it doesn't.
Maybe it comes to a sort of gay,
heterosexual,
I dunno.
I like flowers.
I realized that about myself.
I bought a couple of bases and every week I come off the road I was actually
arranging them today like measuring the stems and looking at the colors to try
to set them up.
I've got like these daisies,
right?
I got one is yellow ones like this sort of like a,
you have a sea of fender strat.
When they got that sunburst finish,
that's what it looks like.
Then I got like these three lavender one.
So put the lavender ones in the back.
They'd like the backup singers.
You know what I mean?
You know like those,
those big black chicks they always have behind the skinny white girl.
Can't fucking sing.
You know
that's how I arrange them.
I put the Pale ones out front.
That's like Paul Simon.
That's what it is.
It's like Paul Simon on the rhythm of the saints tour.
That's how I arrange them and I don't know,
I look at them,
they make me feel good
and you know,
I'm comfortable enough with myself to be able to admit that.
All right,
another overrated thing.
Somebody said Notre Dame and he said I can go on forever forever about this one.
But the amount of assets that a blue chipper gives up not playing in places like
South Beach,
Miami or southern California.
Cause he just had to wait cause he just had to wear the gold helmet sickens me.
Oh isn't that truth?
That's the truth.
Yeah.
But he played for the University of Miami.
Man,
that's a fucking dangerous place.
That's a Goddamn dangerous placement.
You guys have fatalities on the regular,
on your teeth?
And I just say on the regular,
whether they rent fucking Friday last night,
how do I start off saying bananas and then I go with only on the regular,
um,
you know,
something,
I always wanted to go to university of Miami game,
but I wanted to go when they played in the orange bowl.
Now they play in the Joe Robbie.
It just doesn't seem right.
You know what I mean?
Um,
okay.
Another thing,
overrated Asian Pussy.
I'm not sure what I was expecting,
but I'll be honest.
I was expecting more.
Uh,
well did you ever think that maybe the Asian you hooked up with wasn't good in
bed?
I mean,
you're going to judge an entire continent.
You know what's funny is when people say Asian immediately,
myself included as an,
everybody thinks,
you know,
Chinese,
Japanese,
Korean,
Vietnamese,
anybody,
you know,
with the,
uh,
quote unquote,
Asian eyes,
one of the politically correct way of,
of saying what the fucking Spanish basketball team was trying to do.
But that also could be mean.
You hooked up from somebody from India and they stuck in bed.
You know what I mean?
I think you should.
Uh,
listen,
there's fucking hotties.
Well,
you know what,
this,
this deserves a followup question.
How many Asians did you hook up with before you decided to do an entire
continent of pussy?
I mean,
that,
that's pretty amazing when it's one of the biggest continence out there.
If not the biggest is it?
I have no fucking,
it was Africa.
Bigger Africa's bigger,
but I got to tell you something.
Asia is on the rise too.
So,
you know,
be watch what you say.
Okay?
You saw what China did in the Olympics.
They can do that on the rings.
Just think what they can do when the fucking,
I dunno.
Computer industry.
All right,
let's get to a,
let's get the underrated,
underrated.
This guy says,
our early ninety's gangster rap videos,
hands down the greatest videos ever made.
Just a bunch of black dudes hanging out in Compton with their baseball caps
blurred out.
I miss those days.
Uh,
I gotta agree with you,
man.
Those were fucking great days from that time.
They was that really pretty girl at the party and they all shake up their
forties and they dump it on her head because she,
you know,
she thought she was the shit.
You know what the reality is,
is they were looking at her thinking that she thought that she was the shit for
all you know,
she was fucking,
she was probably insecure,
like a lot of beautiful women are.
He always got some sort of hangup.
Oh my God,
I hate my ankle.
You know,
some,
she was probably thinking that because she wasn't wearing jeans.
She's wearing that little hoary outfit.
So she's actually in our head,
which caused her to have a shutdown look on her face.
So then snoop it or whoever,
Dre or Warren g will ever the fuck it was out there in Cali.
They all sell it goes bitch.
She,
she's all fucking stuck up.
And then they shook up their forties and they dumped it over a fucking head and
she probably ran home crying thinking that they did it because they didn't like
our ankles.
And you know what?
That probably led to her being a stripper.
That's how it happens.
All right?
Uh,
underrated.
Ricky Gervais'.
This made two great TV shows and less than five years,
less than five years of each other.
And he still doesn't get the Kudos he deserves.
Maybe it's because there's no laugh track.
Who knows?
I gotta say something.
Ricky Gervais' is a fucking genius.
And if you never saw the original version of the office,
no offense to the American version,
it's unbelievable.
You,
that guy,
that guy is a genius.
That one,
I can't remember the,
what the episode was about,
but that one where he plays the guitar in the middle of the meeting is the most
uncomfortable,
hilarious fucking thing I've ever seen.
And that guy,
I liked how he has a drinking problem and how being an alcoholic is still funny
in England.
You can make fun of people having drinking problems over here.
It's early.
We got to have an intervention.
Why are you doing this to yourself?
Um,
all right,
we're winding down here.
Uh,
the movie basketball,
David Zucker and the south park guys together,
a very underappreciated movie.
You know what?
I got to rent that because when I looked at the trailer,
I'm like,
that looks fucking stupid.
And then a comedian that I respected sought and told me it was hilarious and it
was a good movie.
And,
uh,
I'm going to rent that,
I'm going to rent that fucker.
Uh,
speaking of which,
I finally saw Miller's crossing and,
and,
and I got to admit,
uh,
John Turturro is fucking unreal.
And that movie got,
damn it.
That was a good fucking movie.
Um,
all right,
last thing.
Last thing for this week's underrated list is rage.
The machine.
This guy says,
in my opinion,
the best band in the past 20 years.
Wow.
And for all the shit that's going on in the world now,
their music was way before its time.
That original album is genius from start to finish.
My only complaint was when I saw them at Randall's island last year.
It was rage against the machine brought to you by rockstar energy drink.
That upset me as well.
It should as well it should.
But you know something.
That's what happens after awhile.
After awhile you get into middle age and you're like,
you know what?
At some point I'd like to sleep on a bed.
I'd like to have a fucking couch.
And you know what,
I drink rockstar energy drink.
It tastes good to me.
So if they want to fucking finance the God damn for what?
Do I care?
I mean,
do they have eight year olds putting rock star drink into fucking coke cans over
in Thailand?
Because if that's the case,
I won't support it.
Okay.
But if it's somebody used to build fucking,
I don't know where the fuck I'm going with this.
Anyways,
I want to thank everybody for listening to my podcast and like I said,
if you do it on my page,
which I keep saying because I,
well,
I'm hoping I have some new people with the new special out.
Um,
I do one of these every week to give you a laugh.
At the beginning of the week,
I answer questions people send in their underrated overrated,
uh,
lifts.
I'm trying to get an a,
a new,
uh,
lists going because I'm starting to think that that one is,
I think we've,
I think we've pretty much handled it at this point.
Um,
keeps sending those in.
But if anybody wants to start a new list,
please by all means,
because,
uh,
I do not have creative control of the podcast.
If you want to switch the direction of it,
just send me a funny fucking email that spins the off.
I'll babble about something else.
Maybe somebody else will add to it and that's how it happens.
Huh?
Isn't that interesting?
All right,
so this week coming up,
I'm going to be a,
I'm actually doing a college gig at a with Charlie Murphy and uh,
Umass Amhurst in Boston.
Now it's a private show.
So that's only for students unless you somehow wink,
wink,
figure out a way to sneak in,
which you didn't hear here,
which of course you did because now it's the podcast.
I don't advocate doing that.
I don't advocate putting on a baseball hat and looking like you are of college
age and trying to just sort of walk a walk in with the rest of the students.
I do not advocate doing that.
Okay.
Don't do that.
That would really make me upset.
All right there.
I'm in the clear now.
Um,
and the following week,
September 11th through the 11,
20 and 30,
I think the 13th,
I'm going to be at the punchline in San Francisco and the weekend after that,
uh,
what's 11 and seven 11 and 17,
18 1920 and 21 I will be at the funny bone in uh,
Richmond,
Virginia.
Oh,
be vigilant visiting my buddy sludge out there on the radio and uh,
I'll be performing right down there at the mall,
right across some Dick's sporting goods.
How you liked that,
right back down to earth.
One hour special.
I'm on top of the world.
Two weeks later I'm performing across some addicts and Richmond,
Virginia is a fucking reality slap for you.
Um,
and that is it.
And the new DVD,
we'll be out of the special on September 16th.
And I will be selling that fucker.
Right.
All my shows and I'll be autographing autographing it.
And if you buy it and he just want to come to one of my shows and bring it up to
me and you want me to sign it,
I'll sign the fucker.
Cause uh,
I appreciate you buying them.
And that is it.
And for those of you who want to know what the extras are on it really quick,
uh,
I have the Philadelphia rant is one of the extras,
the classic cell phone footage from the show in Camden,
New Jersey where I got booed in front of all those people.
He,
everybody knows what it is.
So that I got that on there.
I got the uninformed one where I had my radio show where me and Joe got an a
huge argument and then we ended up,
we tried to settle it with a drum battle.
And,
uh,
then I got some other footage of me just going around to the New York clubs,
talking about different horrific sets that I've had over the years,
just telling the story.
So ton of extras and all that bullshit.
And now I'm done babbling.
Thank you so much for listening.
You guys all have a good weekend next week.
I actually will do it on Monday on the Monday morning podcast.
There you go,
everybody have a good week.
All right.
Bye.
Yeah.